en 2010 8 56 67% des votants avaient
répondu non à la proposition
d'indépendance le 4 octobre prochain les
habitants de nouvelle calédonie seront
de nouveau appelés aux urnes pour se
prononcer sur l'indépendance de
l'archipel
ce référendum rentre dans le cadre de
l'accord de nouméa signé en 1998 et qui
envisage notamment l'avenir
institutionnel de la nouvelle-calédonie
deux parties s'opposent historiquement
indépendantistes et anti
indépendantistes un nouveau vote qui
n'inquiète pas particulièrement les élus
locaux favorables à l'indépendance
même si certains évoquent quelques
tensions via les réseaux sociaux
la plupart se dit serein l'ambiance on
allait dire que les semaines à part
quelques accrochages qui ont eu lieu ce
week-end par rapport à une bâche à la
province sud
mais nous nous allons certainement nous
les indépendantistes à ce deuxième
rendez vous inscrit dans les accords du
maire pensant quand même que dans les
débats
ça se corse notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux on sent beaucoup de deux
polémiques sur
la vision que l'on a de de la
consultation pour le oui
le 4 octobre mais nous on pense qu'il
n'y a pas du tout question de d'être
contre la france c'est simplement comme
dessiner un nouvel avenir et bien sûr de
voir les nouveaux liens au contraire que
l'on peut tisser avec l'état français
pour les partisans du non rester
français est une réelle chance pour la
population on sent que les partis sont
mobilisés des deux côtés j'ai la
conviction que la france est une chance
pour tous les calédoniens et y compris
pour les kanaks indépendantistes puisque
la chance apporte non seulement la
liberté mais garanti
les cultures non selon garantie mais
promouvoit également les cultures et en
particulier la cure toute nature kanak
les citoyens de l'archipel sont quant à
eux plus partagés et la place pour tout
le monde ici on peut tous ensemble
j'espère que ça sera le nom pour
l'indépendance qu'on va rester français
et que ben il ya des petits mouvements
mais bon j'espère que ça va s'arranger
voilà il ya de la place pour tout le
monde on peut vivre tous ensemble même
drapeau avec les deux drapeaux
je sais pas trop c'est dur de voir le
port et le compte dans l'es2 enfin le
ski et le mieux parce que je pense que
chaque partie à quelque chose
d'intéressant
enfin les deux réponses of quelque chose
ailleurs intéressant nouvelle calédonie
mais il reste donc un peu moins de trois
mois aux habitants de nouvelle calédonie
pour faire leur choix
histoire d'apaiser les tensions
actuelles